media of course were just drooling over
this
because they've been waiting for four
long years for donald trump to go away
and this was going to be the restoration
now yes it's the restoration of the
pre-trump era
and the media have created this mythical
wonderful obama era in the same way
that jfk's administration was camelot
the obama era was
scandal-free the only bad thing that
ever happened is he wore a tan suit
everybody loved each other sure there
were race riots in 2016 and cops got
shot on the streets in dallas
and sure we had this lowest economic
recovery in a century but you know
everything was fantastic
under obama and now we get to return to
that magical time chris wallace
was just enamored of the speech he said
this is the best inaugural address
i have ever heard well
okay say three lines of it really
right now what was the most memorable
part of that speech
here is chris wallace we must end this
uncivil war and the way we can do it is
if we show each other a little tolerance
and humility
martha i thought it was a great speech
i've been listening to these inaugural
addresses since 1961
john f kennedy asked not i thought this
was the best
inaugural address i ever heard it was
just wonderful
because he said he said we have to end
this uncivil war and then he proceeded
to sign a bunch of incredibly divisive
executive orders into law
and is he going to hold that left in
check
barack obama said exactly the same kind
of stuff as joe biden did yesterday
okay it did not end with america coming
together it ended with an
extraordinarily more divided
america which by the way resulted in the
election of donald trump okay the rest
of the media were even worse than
wallace so
cnn's john king he was like oh my god
it's like a breath of fresh air oh we
can all breathe again we can all go on
vacation because they're just gonna tell
us the truth we're not gonna have to
monitor them we're not gonna have this
trumpy crazy guy out there oh
oh it's just amazing it's like breathing
fresh air ah
john king president bush is happy today
to be there as a republican
even mitch mcconnell who was with
president trump for most of the last
four years
in recent days has made it pretty clear
he wants to shove president trump to the
sidelines if he can to be part
of the republicans trying to do that and
so
there's a cleansing there's a an era of
cleansing about today
there's an internal fight in the
republican party about president trump
soon to be former president trump that's
going to continue okay meanwhile the new
york times headline okay headline this
morning
whether or not related to the former
president's absence a bipartisan
lightness seemed to prevail across the
stage at president joe biden's
inauguration
snow flurries gave way to sun i'm not
kidding that's actually a headline
in the new york times snow flurries gave
way to sun you see the universe itself
was smiling on joe biden the weather
itself reflected
the joy felt by all including god
himself at joe biden's ascension to
power what a magical
moment oh it's like ralph waldo emerson
speaking about how nature reflects us
it's transcendental oh
incredible here's cnn's van jones saying
that this was just it was medicine in
the wounds
he's going to bind us allah it's going
to be oh
everything's healed guys it's all over
america fixed
all your problems over by the way
yesterday was the single greatest covet
death day
of the entire time in america and joe
biden said yesterday
that um they're downplaying their
expectations for vaccine distribution
and all that but
stop that it was amazeballs everything
is gonna
from here on in it's just gravy city
it's going to be unbelievable
here was van jones he spoke from the
depth of his soul
and we needed this you know that was
beautiful
you know beauty heals beauty heals
there was not one part of that that
wasn't just medicine
in the wound and if you have any doubt
that one person can make a difference
that one person's voice one person's
commitment one person's
you know bedrock faith can be the the
pivot point
for a nation just watch that speech
again and look at look at how the
country responds
i mean there's one man who can make a
difference it is this
geriatric old corrupt politician from
delaware who's going to bring us
together now listen
i hope he does i hope that what he means
by unity is actual unity
i have serious serious doubts again the
media coverage here is just
astonishingly ridiculous so my favorite
here
is um the tweets from the celebrities
the tweets from the celebrities are
always the best
because when i need a little bit of
edification i go to extraordinarily rich
and famous people explaining
to me why we need elites running our
lives
oprah winfrey tweeted out decency and
compassion restored hallelujah
president joe biden yes
great reese witherspoon tweet out what
an incredible moment for us all to
witness i i know it was
like like the birth of my child frankly
was watching this old daughtering guy
take office
while the division in our country is
still painfully real i'm optimistic this
is a moment of recommitment to each
other
a commitment to becoming a united states
again today i feel hopeful for the
future
of our nation i'm sure you do now let me
just say this if a republican had taken
office
and uh and then given that exact same
speech like a not trump republican had
taken office and given that exact same
speech
they would not be saying any of this
george w bush that kind of stuff all the
time
left hated him jimmy kimmel who's just a
an activist masquerading as a comedian
say congratulations to our new president
joe biden and vp kamala harris
we know you will do your best to make
america good again
wow ah warms the cockles of your heart
doesn't it
and then we've got kerry washington
again all these are democratic activists
so much work to do but today i want to
celebrate and pray and revel in our
tremendous power
even against all odds to make history
happen yeah that's the part they care
about right
it's the tremendous power unlimited
power
this one was my favorite personally this
is mindy kaling an extraordinarily rich
famous talented and powerful woman
tweeting out a picture of her daughter
watching the inauguration
of kamala harris and saying it matters
happy inauguration you know what
honestly until until mindy kaling's
daughter
saw kamala harris become vice president
she'd never known that women could be
powerful and rich except for her mother
who's extremely powerful and rich
i mean she needed to see kamala harris
on tv it was it was very very important
i hate this kind of crap i hate it with
a passion uh
yeah i i've never said to my i have two
daughters
i will never say to them look at that
politician until you saw that politician
didn't you believe
that you were limited but now you see
they never would have said that if sarah
palin had been elected vice president in
2008 obviously
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content